you
I served from October 1982 to November
2002 I served from 2005 to 2009 from
June 2010 to December 2013 I served from
1989 until 2011 I served from 1991 to
today and I will always remember my oath
I will always will always remember
always remember my oath I will always
remember my health
I John Lewis I Mike Hardin I Hannah's I
sir hi Michael Marie I Bruce Leon likes
do solemnly swear that I will support
and defend that I will support and
defend the Constitution of the United
States against all enemies foreign and
domestic that I will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same that I take this
obligation freely and without mental
reservation or purpose of evasion and
that I will obey the orders of the
President of the United States and the
orders and the officers appointed over
me according to regulations and the
Uniform Code of Military Justice and
that I will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office on
which I am about to entrance at the
office on which I'm about to enter so
help me God so help me God so help me
God so help me God so help me God
you